le bal au petit moulin des votes cerner
un retour aux traditions du 19e durant
une après-midi du 21e siècle les outils
agricoles le lavoir pour nettoyer son
linge tout cela dans le cadre champêtre
de la haute vallée de chevreuse
il y avait des tables et à l'auberge qui
étaient des tables et qui pouvaient
réunir une bonne vingtaine trentaine de
personnes en un seul jour avec toute une
série d'animations qui montre ce qu'on
faisait à l'époque
du point de vue du point de vue de la
peinture bien entendu mais pas seulement
aussi du point de vue de la détente
puisque c'était un lieu aussi de visites
de détente
le fait que ce soit complètement libre
complètement d'époque aussi et
conviviale c'est vraiment joli et la
naturelle et à l'état
sauvage enfin j'en sais rien c'est
vraiment joli et ça ça vaut le coup
dépeint le moulin et ses alentours une
source d'inspiration pour une colonie de
peintre tout au long du xixème
romantique naturaliste et paysagistes se
sont succédé dans les 800 pintades et
agde affiche comme corot pelouse mais
aussi beaucoup de peintres étrangers qui
sont venus à paris au grand salon et qui
profitait de grands salons fournir à 40
km de paris pour rester entre amis et
aussi peindre des paysages magnifiques
que vous trouvez dans cette vallée on ne
peut avoir que de l'admiration d'abord
des paysages pareil cas quelle façon
d'inspiration elle bien parce ménages de
végétation de minéraux et d'eau
visiteurs et peintres ont déjà noté la
date de la quatrième édition en 2020
pour une nouvelle danse de nouveaux
coups de pinceau auprès du petit moulin
des vaux de cernay